you know i got to do this i just have to
show you this
soul-crushing knockout is this on
saturday
yeah oh my goodness and i'm not going to
talk about mma no it's just fine
i like i like seeing this i'm
three days ago this is on saturday night
benil darush this guy is a
[ __ ] artist with the hands that's all
i'm going to say what way close
okay
because it was devastating good night
man
it wasn't even it was like on the phone
it sounds like someone thrown like a log
of salami against a
concrete wall oh man this is exactly
what it sounds like when i pull my dick
out this is exactly what it sounds like
when i pull my dick
to a team
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah when i finally opened my fly and
let that thing just hit the floor
it hit man
so listen i know it's up in there i know
a few podcasts ago cody read a tweet
that was like if your dick doesn't come
out
fall come down past your balls don't
even talk to me and
i might have sounded a bit insecure
that's because i just
i know i know how much the world cannot
handle this [ __ ]
tire that i have in my entire
oh yeah it's just roped up just a giant
piece of rubber
just rolled up in my pants this is the
sound that my dick makes when i take it
out because it hits the top of my balls
so hard
because it rests it rests so nicely on
the top it just goes
boom and yeah
the weight of my balls is
you know the weight of my dick my tiny
dick into my balls has created this oven
mitt of a ball sack
so when i lift up my ball my dick and i
drop it into my nuts
it's like a it's like a baseball hitting
a glove man just [ __ ]
perfect perfect
[Laughter]
dog this guy holtzman took like
i'm not exaggerating like a good five or
six
it may be more like comatose level
punches i feel like darush even had this
look on his face he was like you're not
done
there's no there's no way you're not
done and then just hit him with the
spinning back fizz
the walk-off after that he did was just
so like yeah
let's see i don't know if they show it
that's
spinning backfist this is the most like
mortal kombat
video game move ever aren't they oh yeah
yeah yeah
i mean i've mentioned the twister before
right what's that
it's this weird like you're almost like
cuddling on the ground but you're like
you've trapped the lower body and you
twist their spine
and that works there's been a few who
have done it yeah
it's such a crazy tap so they have to
tap out because what they'll
get paralyzed yeah like their whole
spine is being twisted
it's like the weird it's the weirdest
it's the
weirdest [ __ ] the dude's like
the dude's like holding on to him like a
[ __ ] snake
like wrapped fully wrapped around his
body yeah
slowly tightening yeah he's like how are
you even doing this
bro um this is an old one this is from
eight years ago
but i'm just i'm only pulling this up so
you can see
the position that you have to get into
it's so strange
it's like is that it yeah it's like
you're spooning them
he really is
he's like yeah he really is
this should be called the big spoon yeah
yeah the little spoon
that little spoon tap out yeah oh and he
made him his little spoon
oh he's going for the little spoon he's
going for the little spoon
oh he's scratching his back
yeah this dude there's only been a few
but uh yeah
it's such a weird [ __ ]
play the just play this one more time i
want to see you guys you want to
do you want the sound you want the sound
yeah
here we go
that one hit and i just like i like
honestly
um uh
i i mean i don't i'm not trying to
recycle [ __ ] here but honestly like when
i saw that like i feel like a spinning
back fist for an mma fan
it's like when a woman gets to try
the rabbit for the first time like it's
just like just like
this is like release of testosterone
this is like ah
this is what i've been missing oh all
these years
yeah it's like it's like a it's like a
wife with a dead bedroom
it's like her first orgasm after the
divorce it's like yeah level of just
like oh
yeah yeah oh
[Applause]
yes
that is the card i've needed ah
ah that's funny that's what i've been
waiting for all these fights
left me with nothing and now
just say your co-workers kid's birthday
he invited you do you mind if i put on
the ufc car no man not at all
you know my my brother-in-law likes ufc
you're just sitting there on the couch
by yourself and the brother-in-law's
like hey man i love a good fight man
they're like yeah yeah totally
oh
you're holding his shoulder your leg is
shaking
hey man are you okay are you okay
[Music]
don't move don't move don't move don't
move
leg is bugging the [ __ ] out
are you hey man what are you doing
just [ __ ] no move don't move oh don't
touch me don't touch him
i'm gonna squirt i'm gonna squirt oh my
god
[Laughter]
oh man oh did you just squirt in this
spinach dip oh
i'm not gonna lie man that's a crazy
stream though i don't know how you got
it that far
that is like 12 feet beautiful stream
brother man
i've never seen anybody make a man
squirt 12 feet before
i haven't i haven't seen a spinning back
fist like that since college
just says before i was married just
falls back on the couch puts in the
cigarette
takes a shot lights it up drops an egg
in it
thumbs up
he likes the cigarette then he downs it
oh my god
did he nut from the mma again
yeah he did and then you're just sitting
like
bro you're like hooking up with your
girl
you're like no you're [ __ ] you're mid
[ __ ] and she's like
do you want to like put something on be
a little crazy
he's like oh yeah i got something
beneal darush spinning back fist
cross-legged yeah like a child at the
foot of the bed watching the tv she's
like
well i mean like i she's just
still laying behind you in lingerie i
meant like something dirty
here come here no trust me babe this
fist this back fist
it's as dirty as it gets it's so dirty
it's so dirty but neil's such a bad boy
so dirty
oh see wasn't that sick
[ __ ] there i'll replay it i don't
think i don't think you saw it
listen to the noise
now to now picturing college couple
hooking up
tell me something dirty dude [ __ ]
bryson
we were playing beer pong last week like
goes on like a tangent
he's a shot with his eyes closed behind
the back
so [ __ ] dirty
no i mean something like you know
oh oh my bad okay yeah no for sure okay
um yeah like something like you know
tell me what something disgusting
so [ __ ] davis but you know
viola he was hooking up with her finger
blaster
comes back plays beer pong with us
doesn't wash his hands
sticks his finger into the water cub
touches all the balls shoots one
didn't tell us till after the party
[ __ ]
dirty right no i mean babe like tell me
something
like you know something's like sexy
oh okay
so like davis is [ __ ] this other
chick right
uh he comes back he shows us pictures
this girl's a perfect
ten i swear to god and she was like
totally cool with it like he asked her
so like consent so sexy
right no tell me something sexy all
right dude this new freshman kid
takes a beer puts it in his mouth and
does like this like swirling like
cylinder thing oh i mean it wasn't like
sexy like i didn't
i didn't think it was but like something
like something
about it was definitely sexy yeah
or like you know that's not maybe that's
that's not the word but like i you know
but you know what i mean like there's no
way like it was like
for me but like it's for somebody you
know what i mean and like i appreciated
that
it's sexy like in the way like art is
sexy
like i don't want to have sex with it
but i can appreciate looking at it
yo no capful that was [ __ ] hot
i'm not even gonna cap you down bro [ __ ]
was [ __ ] hot
yo you sucked down big beers homie
straight up
shit's hot i sent that video to my gay
cousin and he was like that's hot
and honestly i had to agree bro
co-signed bro from me and my cousin it's
just
fire dog got me questioning my [ __ ]
am i turned on yeah like maybe
i don't know yeah you know what i'm just
gonna go home
like you've just been talking to
yourself for the past 20 minutes i'm
just
i'm gonna go back to my dorm
uh finish off with the spinning backfist
i don't feel like we did enough with the
frat frat boy museum
what do you mean like i was just
picturing i was just picturing like
like an actual frat boy museum like
white walls and it's like framed
beer beer pong cups and stuff like that
and the guy's like
yeah this is man this is this is stuff
of legends right here
nah man it's a room with a roar in a
glass box
and someone walks in and it's like so
what it i mean bro it's a roar
it's a roar like that bong company roar
oh yeah oh yeah yeah right i mean
that's that's like the little silver
plaque on it yeah
it's a roar say no more
i mean that's kind of the beauty of like
this whole room is like we shouldn't
even be talking right now because
there's nothing to say
yeah like just use your eyes
that's actually why we have these
commentary headphones
he puts them on i mean nuff said it's a
roar it's a roar
just looping you see you see the
percolators on that thing
i've said too much
it's a already
[Laughter]
enough said it's a roar enough said it's
a roar enough said it's a roar
enough said it's a roar enough said it's
a roar that's in the headphones and
it looks to the frat dude standing in
front of it he just nods up
couldn't couldn't agree more
you